and CBS News senior foreign affairs
correspondent and moderator of Face the
Nation that's Margaret Brennan she's in
Washington Margaret good morning things
are not looking good in that region and
a lot of people say this is exactly as
it was expected when US troops were
pulled out of the region what are your
sources telling you about what the
administration may face now that chaos
seems to be ensuing well there is a
divide between people who follow and
know the Middle East and the President
himself and an exasperated source said
to me that this could be the end of the
Trump presidency the president does not
appreciate the implications of his
decision to pull US troops out of Syria
which will allow Turkey to continue its
advance for the people who do know the
region within the administration they
are arguing that the decision amounts to
a demolition of US power in the region
that will only benefit Russia Iran
Bashar al Assad and Isis yet the
president is convinced that he is doing
this country a favor by pulling out a
relatively small number of troops there
is no broader strategy or policy all of
this is being retrofitted to fit the
president's decision to withdraw it's
interesting though Margaret that some of
his staunchest allies are speaking out
against him to Lindsey Graham and Mitch
McConnell that's you really don't see
that happen very often you don't and
unfortunately for them it's it's falling
on deaf ears their calls for the
president to rethink this decision just
had no effect and in fact the president
doubled down with that late Saturday
night decision to pull everyone out and
it's also interesting that the Pentagon
itself is saying that there are many
dangerous Isis detainees in Syria right
now who have been released and so you
have the administration warning that
Isis is running all over eastern Syria
virtually unchecked that the president
doesn't seem concerned that it's going
to destroy his narrative of having
defeated Isis that could hurt him when
he's on the campaign trail but he
believes all of this isn't his problem
but rather the problem of Turkey in
Europe if there's a terror attack
Margaret what impact are these new
sanctions and this visit from vice
president pence likely to have
on Turkey sanctions are gonna punish
Turkey but they're not gonna prevent
anything they're punitive they're not
preventive the actions already been
taken and the administration briefed
reporters yesterday and said basically
there's nothing America could do to stop
Turkey once
Erewhon consolidates his gains the
ceasefire that they're expected to try
to broker with vice president pence will
still benefit Russia as well as Iran and
Turkey Margaret Brennan thank you
Margaret